have a new restaurant from food network
star vic vegas opens right here in the
valley today
yeah chef's black and blue diner even
feature some vegan options
jack holman is there live this morning
with a look good morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
you know i got my cup of chock full of
nuts coffee in this cup all my seinfeld
watchers you'll recognize this cup right
so we are here at black and blue diner
joined by chef vic
vegas tell us what you whipped up for us
already took a bite of this
amazing waffle so you took a bite of the
amazing house waffle and now
this is one of the items that i'm big on
vegan vegan steak and eggs
it looks so good cannot not have steak
and eggs in vegas but this looks like a
real egg what kind of egg is this yes
those are easy eggs plant-based yep
plant-based eggs all the way plant-based
eggs plant-based steak
the potatoes done with margarine no
animal product
cooked separately in its own green pans
where you know we're isolating any type
of vegan food from any type of animal
protein good to know and
typically diners have pages full of food
you're overwhelmed but here you've been
able to streamline it you got some great
options pictured up there
tell us about your choices for this
donna because you've opened up several
restaurants before
how did you make this so unique i think
the reason why this is unique this is
more of my food journey on what i
ate to become a chef growing up in
brooklyn on 75th street and fifth avenue
staten island in jersey my dad my mom
they used to take me to these type of
places and as i became a chef and as i
got older living in las vegas since 89
i wanted to see it i wanted to see it
and you have amazing diners around here
that belong to las vegas i said you know
what it's time to bring
some of my memories to this town for
sure and tell me i know open up a dirt
opening during a pandemic
it's already hard opening up a
restaurant but tell me the changes you
all made here because you
had to do some structural things to this
old arby's to open during this pandemic
you know something that was a
frustration oh no we can't build this no
more oh no
we're gonna have to wait it was a
blessing in disguise because what it did
was
it allowed me to make the boots a little
higher
perfectly separate people a little more
create a comfort zone put dividers
between the tables
exactly and make it more of a pandemic
friendly restaurant even when the
pandemic
ends let's keep this secure of a good
feeling here when
people walk in so you got dining options
drive-through options of course delivery
you're doing it all to make sure that
people can get a great breakfast
great lunch uh tell me how are you
feeling because y'all are opening up
here and like
i don't have a watch but uh in about 20
minutes y'all open up at seven
yeah we're gonna open up at seven
o'clock um you know it's we're blessed
to have you guys here first of all to
let everybody know about it
and what we're just looking to do here
is to be a staple for the people of las
vegas because
you don't really look at a diner as a
restaurant it's almost food you would
have made it home yeah but you don't
want to wash the dishes
and when you walk in the diner someone's
going to know your name as we get to
know you
get your coffee ready and we're going to
know what you want to eat as we get to
know you
wonderful so again they open up at seven
black and blue diner we're right here at
decatur and meadows
perfect location come out and support
local
restaurants homegrown and our great chef
uh chef vic vegas and his team
thank you all for opening up to us we're
gonna send it back to you guys in the
studio i need to bite some of this uh
egg and mushrooms looking so good there
you go little vegan steak and eggs for
you
a little hot sauce on the side it looks
to die for
bianca did you try the waffle
oh maybe she's is eating the waffle it
looks like she had a little bit yes
it was so good it was so good yes that
was my bite
perfect it was good got the strawberry
the whipped cream
i only took a bite because i'm ready to
dive into that
okay well go ahead bianca enjoy thank
you so much and we wish uh
we wish him the very best with his new
restaurant looks amazing